MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Hello,
big data and Big Query
developers.
My name is Michael Manoochehri
from the Google Developer
Relations team for the Google
Cloud Platform.
And I'm here with my good
friend, Felipe Hoffa.
And today, we're going to talk
to you about a feature that
people have been asking
us for a lot.
And every time I'm on this show,
I take pride in the fact
that the Big Query engineering
team listens to developer
feedback and presents to you the
features that you've been
asking for.
So today, we're going to talk
about one that people have
been asking for for
a long time.
And I think a lot of developers
are going to be
interested.
So Felipe, can you tell us a
little bit about this feature
that people have been
asking us for?
FELIPE HOFFA: Hi, Michael.
Hi, everyone.
How are you doing?
Yes, as Michael says,
we are always adding
functions to Big Query.
We're always adding
new features.
The generating team
is amazing.
And today we are doing this show
because there is a new
function that we really wanted
to take the time to introduce
to show how it works and to show
the big potential it has.
Do you know what this
function is?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
so can you tell me a
little bit about it?
I heard the name
is Correlation.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, it's
Pearson correlation.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So what is
correlation, first of all,
and what is Pearson's
correlation?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, in this case,
Pearson correlation is a
mathematical function where
if you have two series of
numbers, you can see how well
related they are linearly
between each other.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Can you
give me an example of, like,
what could those numbers be?
FELIPE HOFFA: For example,
let's say as you get high
temperatures, do you sell
more or less ice creams?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I'm guessing more.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, exactly.
So there you have a linear
correlation we should be able
to express as a number.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I see.
So if you collect data about
what the temperature is over
the course of the day or over
the course of the week and how
many ice cream cones you sell,
you can actually run these
numbers through this formula
and get a number that
expresses how well correlated
the numbers are.
That's how I understand it.
Does that sound right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, for
example if every time that the
temperature increases, you sell
more ice cream, and as
the temperature goes down, you
sell less ice creams, that's a
positive correlation.
The closest to one, when you
calculate it, it's the more
aligned each of these variables
are to each other.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right,
right, and you can also test
for things you don't
know about.
So maybe people are selling
notebook computers or
Chromebooks, and you don't know
if it's related to the
temperature or not.
Maybe it is.
Who knows?
And so you can take the same
approach to other things that
probably you don't know if
they're correlated or not.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
Let me show you with a
[INAUDIBLE] example.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Excellent.
FELIPE HOFFA: This is my IPython
notebook, and I'm
starting to use it.
I love it.
If any of you viewers have tips
on how to do this better,
please tell me.
Because I'm just starting
with it.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Definitely.
FELIPE HOFFA: So let's start
importing some of the
[? Magic ?]
functions--
Panda, [INAUDIBLE]
library, [INAUDIBLE]
library.
Let's play a little with this.
For example, what was the
temperature yesterday?
Let's say you sell ice cream.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yesterday,
it was pretty moderate.
I'd say it was 21.
I'm going to use Celsius.
FELIPE HOFFA: Celsius, OK.
That's one way to international
viewers.
[INAUDIBLE]
Fahrenheit, so even
better for me.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
OK, great.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yesterday,
it was 21.
And how many ice creams did
you sell yesterday?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Well, I sold seven
ice cream cones yesterday.
FELIPE HOFFA: Seven
ice creams.
Seven or 70?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK, it
was very popular, so 70.
FELIPE HOFFA: 70,
let's say 70.
And do you remember last week?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Oh yeah,
last week was really hot.
It was super hot--
30 degrees.
FELIPE HOFFA: 30 degrees--
yeah, that's
super hot in Celsius.
How many ice creams
did you sell?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I sold way more.
I sold 180 ice cream cones.
FELIPE HOFFA: 180
ice cream cones.
And what about two weeks ago?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: There was
a cold snap two weeks ago.
Well, it was colder.
Let's say it was around
16 degrees.
FELIPE HOFFA: 16 degrees.
And how many ice creams
did you sell?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Ice
cream trade wasn't
going well that day.
35.
FELIPE HOFFA: 35, that's
[INAUDIBLE].
OK, now we have three days.
If we compare it to if
we have three days of
service, we can plot this.
Let's see how well they
look together.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
what do we see here?
Is this the line we
kind of expected?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, yes, yes.
You can see the green line
and the blue line.
The blue line, if you
compare it to, they
are both up and down.
And the ice cream sold also
goes up and down.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So but in
the graph, it doesn't look
like there's a strong connection
between these two.
FELIPE HOFFA: But you can
see that there is some
correlation.
What we can build to better
look at the relationship
between these two variables is
instead of looking at them on
time, with can plot one
next to each other
on a scatter plot.
Let's look at that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It looks
like it looks like there's a
strong kind of a line that goes
through all of these.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, when the
temperature was 16, we saw
less than 40.
When the temperature
was 21, we saw 70.
And when the temperature
was 30, we saw 180.
You can see that there
is a linear
relationship between both.
And we can get a number for it
with asking for correlation.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So this is
running what you call the
Pearson's r.
You're going to do the Pearson
r correlation between these
series of numbers.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, I want
to know how linearly
correlated these numbers are.
Let's run it.
0.99.
This is almost one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So does
this mean a high correlation?
FELIPE HOFFA: This means a
very high correlation.
The hotter it is, the more
ice creams we sell.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Right, so just to
get kind of a ballpark.
So as I recall, Pearson's
r goes from--
I think, it's negative one
to one is the scale.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, sir.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So a
zero would be, like, no
correlation at all.
Something closer to one means
a very strong positive
correlation.
And if it's negative, that
means it's a negative
correlation, meaning when one
number goes up, the other one
tends to go down.
Does that sound right?
FELIPE HOFFA: That
sounds right.
Let's run another example.
Let's see negative
correlation.
For example, you also
sell coats.
You remember that day
that was the first
day, it was 21 degrees?
How many coats did you sell.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Well, I sold 25.
FELIPE HOFFA: 25.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Well, a
lot of people buy coats.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, 25
coats-- pretty good.
The day that was so hot--
the 30 degree day.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
I sold very few.
I sold 10.
FELIPE HOFFA: You sold 10.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Somehow,
I sold 10 that day.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, and how many
did you sell that day
that we were colder--
16 degrees?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: 47.
FELIPE HOFFA: 47, OK,
let's plot that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: All these
numbers are true, everyone.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I have
a coat ice cream store in
Mountain View.
FELIPE HOFFA: Ice
cream and coats.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Ice
FELIPE HOFFA: Here we can see
the line is going down.
The hotter it gets, the
less coats you sell.
And we can see what the
correlation number is.
For the numbers you
just gave me, the
correlation is minus 0.96.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: All right,
so a strong negative
correlation.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, it's--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Going down.
FELIPE HOFFA: Going down,
almost minus one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: All right,
so now I know what to
sell when it's hot or cold at
Michael's Ice Cream and Coat
Shop in Mountain View,
California.
So this is great.
So it seems like this problem
is easy to solve on your
IPython notebook.
So when would this be hard to do
with your IPython notebook.
Why would we need something
like Big
Query in this example?
FELIPE HOFFA: If you have three
letter points, if you
are looking at two series,
it's very to do
it on your own computer.
It totally depends on how much
data can fit in your computer.
But sometimes, data can't
fit into your computer.
You have terabytes of data,
you have gigabytes of data
you've [INAUDIBLE] in a lifetime
or all at once.
And that's when Big
Query comes in.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So just
for the people that don't
know, Google Big Query is an API
to an analytical database
that lets you run queries over
your own data in seconds.
I mean, you can actually run
queries over gigabytes and
gigabytes of data and get the
result back in seconds.
It's a great developer's tool,
because it's all access
through an API.
So you can actually write
code to access it.
We also have a UI that you
can use to run queries.
And so this is fantastic.
So we've taken this correlation
function.
And we've actually applied it
to very large data sets.
So not just stuff that you can
keep on your notebook, but
things that are really massive,
the gigabytes and
terabytes of data.
FELIPE HOFFA: So what we might
do now for everyone is let's
pick a data set, a massive one,
and let's look what kinds
of correlations we
can find in them.
Do you have any favorite
data set?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes, so I
have a data set that I love.
It's one that a lot of people
use for things like
correlation.
It's the [? Reda ?]
On Time Airline database, which
is kind of put together
by the Department of
Transportation.
I love this data set.
You can actually go Google
it and find it's.
It's all available
for you to use.
And I've taken about three years
of data and put it into
Big Query from this database.
So basically if you go
to my laptop, I'll
show you the web UI.
It basically gives you the date,
an airline code, the
departure airport and arrival
airport, and also the delays,
how the flight was delayed.
Was it delayed five minutes?
And if it took off early, it'll
have a negative number
for the delay.
And same thing with
the arrival.
So was it delayed on arrival?
Was it five minutes late?
Was it five minutes early?
This is a great data set, not
only because it's huge.
Right now, I don't even have the
entire data set in there.
I have about 70 million
records.
FELIPE HOFFA: 70 million
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
70 million records.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
70 million flights
recorded of the query.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes, over
all of the time period.
This is just United
States data too.
There's even more out there.
And it's all on Big Query.
And it's about eight gigabytes
of data in there right now, so
pretty considerable.
It's definitely a lot for, say,
if you're using something
like r-- something that would
be way too slow for r, and
just might not even
fit into memory.
And you'd have to do
all kinds of tricks
with something similar.
Same with IPython.
It might be very difficult to
do timely results and not be
able to do some of the
things we want to.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's amazing.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So yeah,
so let's take a look.
So I'm going to learn
how to use Core.
I've probably used it.
And so we're going to do a
couple queries to see how this
works, and I'm really excited.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's start
things very simple.
Show me a table, please.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So let's
just take a look at the
details of this table.
So if we look at my laptop, this
is sort of what the data
looks like.
Here's the data.
It's just a string.
We have a string.
We have airport code.
So this is, like, Houston in
Texas, and we have some
information about
the departures.
So we have the arrival actual
time and the delay.
So this is what we're actually
looking at is how
many minutes delayed.
So this particular flight,
randomly, that I'm looking at
is delayed three minutes.
And the arrival time was
11 minutes late.
FELIPE HOFFA: So for a flight,
we know when it happened, how
late it was, where did it depart
from, where it was
going to, the airport,
the state.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And we have
some other information as
well, like the latitude
at longitude.
But we're going to be looking
at the times.
FELIPE HOFFA: And 80 million
lines of rows with that data?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes,
exactly, 80 million--
70 million.
FELIPE HOFFA: Which one has
been the worst day?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So, yes,
let's take a look at that.
So we want to do
the worst day.
So that would be we want to
select the date, and would you
want to look at average
departure delay?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, let's look
at the worst average.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK so I'm
going to use the Big Query
function, average, and I'm going
to look at departure
delay, which is just a number.
So I'm looking for average
departure delay
from this data set.
And what do I want to do?
I want to group by date, because
I want to know which
date has the worst average.
And I'm going to label
this as [INAUDIBLE]
g, grouped by date.
So this should give me the days
with, on average, the
worst departure delays for the
entire data set for all of
these years.
So let's run this.
This is now running over
70 gigabytes of data.
And it took three seconds
to return.
So let's take a look at this.
So just looking at these--
FELIPE HOFFA: There is something
missing there.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: What
do we want to do?
FELIPE HOFFA: We want
to sort it.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right,
so this is unsorted.
So we want to sort by the
departure delay time.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, right
now we're looking at each
date, what was the average?
But we loaded them in
a random order.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK, so I'm
going to do something here
with my query.
And I'm going to say data is the
first parameter that we're
looking at in the query, and
average departure delay.
So I'm going to say group
by one, meaning date,
and order by two.
And I also want to do order
by two descending.
FELIPE HOFFA: So that way,
we get the worst day?
When was the delay?
What date were the delays
the greatest?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes, OK.
So let's look at this.
We're going to run this.
We're going to take about
the same time.
In two seconds, we processed
all this data.
And it looks like the worst days
were December 23, 2004,
December 21, 2008--
a lot of times that look like
around Christmas time.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, so what
is that telling us now?
If you are going to fly,
avoid Christmas.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Now
this is common sense.
So a lot of people know
that it's bad.
And we don't actually know
if this is the reason.
Is it really because it's
Christmas time?
When we can infer things,
and we can use this
data to point it out.
It's pretty obvious that
people travel a lot.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, but it's
amazing that the worst days
ever in history are around
Christmas, around New Year is
the fourth one.
What about the second?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So this
is an interesting one.
So these are all kind of
holiday season times--
makes sense.
But the ninth worst
day was around
Valentine's Day in 2007.
And that is a really
interesting--
I would never have
guessed that.
Now, is it because people are
going on Valentine's Day trips
and maybe there's, like, a
romantic getaway that year?
So actually, I was looking
at this data
a little bit earlier.
And I think a lot of people
might know this.
There was a Valentine's Day
storm in 2007, the North
American blizzard.
And that was the reason
why all of those
flights were delayed.
FELIPE HOFFA: I remember
that day.
It was bad.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
It was really bad.
FELIPE HOFFA: It's interesting
to know that that day was bad,
but we have had even
worse days.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes,
we've had worse average
departure delay times, and
there was Christmas.
So this is fantastic.
So now, I've actually learned
something I wouldn't have
learned because of this query.
So what are we going
to do now?
FELIPE HOFFA: Can you show me
the worst days by state?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes, so the
worst days by state, I can
do by grouping by state.
So I want to add one more
thing here, which is--
let's take a quick look
at our schema again.
FELIPE HOFFA: I think it's
departure state.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Departure
state, yes.
So departure state, and I want
to say select the date and
departure date.
I want to group by the departure
state, and I
want to order by--
FELIPE HOFFA: Column three.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So I've
just actually just
changed the group by.
So let's run this.
See how that works.
I love doing these
live queries.
I learn something every
time I do this.
So this is running now.
It should take a little bit
more time because we're
grouping by.
So that took nine seconds.
So now these are the worst,
the order by down.
I don't actually know
what TB stands form.
Wyoming is the second one.
So it looks like some
of these dates--
Wyoming was actually the worst
for whatever reason.
FELIPE HOFFA: In fact, one
important thing when looking
at data and why we are doing
this slide is to highlight
what problems we have when doing
this kind of average.
When we're doing
that [? out, ?]
when doing an average, we really
want to average a lot
of numbers.
If you have only one data
point, it's not very
representative.
So what we can absolutely query
is a count of how many
numbers we are averaging.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So let me
add one more parameter, and
that would be the count.
And so I'm adding count.
I'm going to call
it c, an alias.
So I'm going to just move this
down so people can see.
So now we have the date, the
departure state, the average
departure delay and the count.
So I'm going to just
run this again.
I think everything should look
the same except we'll have now
a count of how many times these
flights were going out.
Great, so now I have one.
So that seems like a pretty
small sample.
What should I do to--?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, it's only
one data point for one
day for one state.
It's not very interesting.
Let's figure out small states,
like if there was only one
flight that day and it was very
delayed, we can't really
say much about this.
So let's have data
points where--
let's have [? evidence ?] when
we have a [? real ?]
number of flights.
Let's have at least 10 flight
from that state.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And this
is where I want to use the
having clause.
So I can say, give me a
result having a count
greater than something.
So if I'm not mistaken, I would
do something like this,
where I say--
let's say the count
greater than 50.
FELIPE HOFFA: Greater than 50.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We
can choose whatever.
So I'm going to run this again,
filtering out some of
these states with
less flights.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's get
real average, not
the loose data points.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right,
so this is great.
So I love this iterative process
of Big Query, because
again, we're going over
70 million records.
So this is an interesting one.
Now we have flights from large
states, large airports,
Oregon, Maryland,
Ohio, Georgia.
Count is 87, 126, et
cetera, et cetera.
FELIPE HOFFA: So the worst
date ever in the recorded
history we have was two days
before Christmas in Oregon.
The average delay that
day was three hours.
That's a lot.
It was a very bad day.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Exactly,
and then you can see another
kind of holiday seasons, around
New Year's, same kind
of thing-- like, huge travel
delays probably
due to a lot of people.
We don't know, but this gives
you a pointer to see why.
FELIPE HOFFA: And this
is awesome, but
we want to go further.
You've always been able to
do this with Big Query.
Now we want to compare state
with out of state.
For example, the data--
New York is bad.
Are there other airports that
are bad at the same time?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
This is fantastic.
So we want to take this data and
actually do a correlation
on some similar data set
or the same data set.
So how do we do that?
FELIPE HOFFA: First, let's
start with a data series.
Let's get the series of all the
other delays per day for
one airport.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK,
or one state maybe.
FELIPE HOFFA: For one state.
Let's do states where we can
have more data points to--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
I'm going to do the
same query, I believe.
But I'm going to add
where departure
state equals something.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, we will
order by date this time,
because we want every day.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK, so
I'm going to order by one.
I'm going to add a where
clause, where
departure state equals--
I can type it--
equals--
pick a state.
FELIPE HOFFA: New York.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: New York--
sounds like a good state.
So here, I'm adding departure
state is from New York.
And going to run this again,
the same query, just by
filtering out all the
other states.
So let's see how this works.
Two seconds later, we
have-- ah, look,
it's around New Year's.
So this isn't ordered.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, let's have
the order now by date.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: By date,
order by date ascending.
This is great.
So I'm just changing the
way it's ordered.
Yeah, it was actually ordered
the wrong way.
So here it is.
So the very first day
in our database--
that's the delay.
This is great.
FELIPE HOFFA: This looks
like a data series.
And we want to run the
correlation between this data
series and our airport.
How correlated, for example,
is New York to California
[INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes,
that's a great idea.
OK, so what should we do next?
FELIPE HOFFA: This is where
we can do assess joint.
We run the same query two times
and add the MS columns.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
I can actually just
take the same query.
I'm going to do a joint.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to wrap
this around in some
parentheses, and
let's call it a.
And I'm going to join
with the same query.
And we'll be able to edit
this in a second.
So I'm going to do a
quick join, and I'm
going to join it on.
And I'll have to do another
select, but I'll show you that
in a second.
So what are we going
to join on?
The date.
FELIPE HOFFA: The date.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So I want
to say a date equals b date.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I
have to call this b, or
whatever you want it
to [INAUDIBLE].
And now that I have this,
I can say select.
I want to say select
a departure
state, b departure state.
And I will spell it correctly.
So I want to do that.
And then I want to select
a average and b average.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes,
that's true.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And what
else do I need to look at?
Do I need to look at
the count as well?
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
look at the count.
It's always interesting to know
that we have enough data
to make a correlation.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So I'll
just do like that.
So this actually should work.
But now I'm comparing New
York to New York.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's not
do the count now.
We are not really aggregating.
And let's compare New
York to California.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So I'll
change one of these to
California.
So this will give us, what?
The average departure delays.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, and to
make this query even more
efficient, you don't really
need to order them.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right,
because it's just actually
just joining.
I'll take these out.
Let's get rid of that step
to make it even faster.
Let's see how this works.
A much larger query
than before--
so just taking a quick look,
making sure that I have
everything correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: You're
missing a from.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Thank
you very much.
FELIPE HOFFA: From
the other select.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I missed a clause.
So that should work.
Thank you for pair programming
with me.
OK, here we go up.
So here is our query.
This is fantastic.
So these are actually
joined on a date.
We have the departure state,
New York to California, and
the average departure delays
every single day.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, so
whenever in New York, we have
an average of 4.2.
California has an
average of 2.8.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Right, interesting.
This is interesting, because
now we have two data sets.
Is this working into
a correlation
between these two states?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, is
there a correlation?
Is there no correlation?
Let's look at that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So the way
I want to do correlation
is the core function, and I
would run the core function on
these two variables, the
averages from both.
So now I'm actually just
slightly changing this query.
I'm adding the core function,
wrapping that
around these averages.
So I should now get a
correlation between the two.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, but
correlation is an aggregate
query, so you need to
group by something.
And we are going to group
by departure states.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Great, so I want to
group by one and two.
FELIPE HOFFA: Awesome.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And when I
say one and two, again, I'm
referring to these first two
columns we're sending.
So now I'm going to
run this again.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
our new shorthand.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I love it.
FELIPE HOFFA: So across this
history, if we look at every
day, New York to California, of
how delayed they were, the
correlation is 0.3.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's kind
of a weak correlation.
FELIPE HOFFA: So there
is correlation.
We can say there is
correlation, but
it's not very strong.
If flights are delayed in New
York, they might be delayed at
California too.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Now, it
just makes some sense because
they're far apart, the plane
can make up time.
Who knows?
There might be no connection.
The weather systems are
different, et cetera.
I don't know the answer,
but there is not a very
significant connection
between these there.
FELIPE HOFFA: What about New
York and New Jersey?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: All right,
so New York and New
Jersey, very connected.
Some of the airlines-- the
planes are similar places.
The weather systems
are similar.
Running the exact same
query again with New
York and New Jersey.
So ah, now look at this.
The correlation is actually
quite strong, 0.83.
FELIPE HOFFA: We went
from 0.3 to 0.8.
This means if there are delays
in New York, it's very
probably that there are delays
in New Jersey too.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right,
so this is fantastic.
So that also makes some sense.
Now we're looking at the entire
data set, we're getting
a really good understanding
of those correlations.
FELIPE HOFFA: That is right.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: That
seems pretty obvious.
Can we do one more kind of query
where we can find things
that are not so obvious?
Like how do we find out things
that we maybe don't know?
FELIPE HOFFA: For example, can
you tell me what's the state
that is most correlated
to New York?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Interesting., the most
correlated to New York.
How would we find that query?
FELIPE HOFFA: We would remove
the selection of states from--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So I don't
actually want to select
any particular state
from each of these.
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, you can
leave New York as the first
one because we want to know
which state is the most
correlated to New York.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes, so I
want to just say I want to
take out the where clause for
my second query, sub query.
And now I can basically
run the same thing.
Now it's going to pick
all the states.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, now we are
running a very big amount of
combinations.
We are combining the data series
from New York to every
other data series we have.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right,
so this is thousands and
thousands of combinations
going through.
Let's try this out.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
sort them without.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So we're
going to sort by--
should we sort by
departure state?
FELIPE HOFFA: By the
correlation.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Order by--
FELIPE HOFFA: So we get the
top correlation first.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Got it.
So I'm going to actually
name this.
I'm going to name this c.
And I'm going to order by--
FELIPE HOFFA: You're going
to go by three.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: By three.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, that's
our shorthand.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I love it.
FELIPE HOFFA: And [INAUDIBLE]
descending.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And we'll
do it descending, good.
So we'll know that the most
correlated first.
OK, got it, great.
So I'm ready to run
this query.
Is this going to be too
many data points?
Let's see.
I think this is going
to be great.
So it's taking just
a few seconds.
So now this is doing a huge
number of combinations.
And five seconds later, ah.
FELIPE HOFFA: The most
correlated state to New York
is New York.
The correlation is one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Good,
that's a good ground truth of
what we've been doing.
FELIPE HOFFA: It's very good to
know that, because it means
that we are doing this right.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
This is fantastic.
And you can see-- this is kind
of interesting-- of course,
New Jersey, Massachusetts,
Pennsylvania--
so states nearby.
It looks like weather is a big
part of that obviously.
We can kind of scroll through
the results--
Rhode Island, New Hampshire,
Florida and Connecticut--
things that are still on
the eastern seaboard.
And then you start to get less
of a correlation as you move
out west, of course.
You've got Kentucky,
and you've got Ohio
and things like that.
FELIPE HOFFA: Show me the
least correlated state.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
so I can just go to last.
And guess what?
It's Hawaii.
FELIPE HOFFA: No way.
And the second one is Alaska.
FELIPE HOFFA: And it's
[INAUDIBLE] you can see.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: There's
actually no correlation
between departure delays,
at least mathematical
correlation.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, whatever is
happening in New York, it
really doesn't affect what's
happening in Hawaii and what's
happening in Alaska.
And something very interesting
to know.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Makes sense.
This is another reason why
if you find interesting
correlations that you
didn't expect--
so I kind of expect this.
I kind of expect the weather to
be-- but what if you found
a state, or an airport or
something where you didn't
expect, like for example, New
York is correlated with--
I don't know, like, Colorado.
And I wouldn't expect that.
So maybe that's pointing to
another problem in the system
where who knows what the
problem could be?
And I'm not saying there
is a correlation.
We don't see that here.
But let's say Colorado and
New York were correlated.
Something else is going on.
Maybe computer systems in those
two venues are broken.
Who knows what it is?
But you can use something like
this to find significant
correlations that point you
toward a problem or something
cool that you want to fix.
FELIPE HOFFA: Or to look
at something else.
Can you look into the
future with this?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
So can you predict?
This is a good question?
FELIPE HOFFA: Can we?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I don't know.
Can we?
What should we do?
FELIPE HOFFA: We can go to the
set correlations, but instead
of correlating the same
day, we can correlate
the previous day.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes
OK, so how we do
that with Big Query?
We have some time functions
we can use.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, we have
take, for example, the second
sub [? select. ?]
And look whatever happened
the day before.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK,
so let me see if I
can build this query.
So we have a function called
Time Stamp, and that will turn
a string into a time stamp,
which is a Big Query data type
that we have native.
And we have another
function called--
I think it's called Date Add.
And Date Add allows you to shift
time back and forth with
these time stamps.
So the Date Add function is one
in which I can say, take
this date, this time stamp.
Well, do want to do one day
differently, two days?
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
do one day.
Let's take the day before.
So add one day to it, yes.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I want
to turn this back into a
date string.
So that's another function
I've called Date.
So I'm basically just running
a bunch of functions on the
string date that we have.
I'm turning it into
a time stamp.
I'm shifting it one day ahead,
and then I'm turning it back
into a string so
we can compare.
So that's a lot of things going
on through 70 million
records, which is great.
Let's run it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's find the
best correlation with New York
back from the previous day.
What's the best predictor
for what will happen
with New York tomorrow?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Let me
just make sure I did this
right-- the date, the time
stamp here and here.
I think that's right.
OK, let's try it.
FELIPE HOFFA: [INAUDIBLE]
queried.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
I'm grouping by--
FELIPE HOFFA: You need to add
date and comma there.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I didn't add that.
Let's run it again.
I forgot my alias.
So this is running over
70 million records.
It's doing this incredible
join.
It's changing the time stamp.
It's doing counts.
FELIPE HOFFA: Looking at
a lot of combinations.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Combinatins, and it's running
a correlation on top of this.
So this is a lot of things
happening over a
really large data set.
It only took 15 seconds.
It's pretty fantastic.
FELIPE HOFFA: So look at
the top results here.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Interesting, so what I'm
looking at is now, this
is really interesting.
So one day ahead, I see some not
super strong correlations,
but kind of medium correlations
between states I
wouldn't have expected--
New York and Tennessee.
FELIPE HOFFA: So this is telling
me that the best
predictor of what is going to
happen in New York tomorrow--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: In terms
of departure delays.
If there's a departure delay
in New York, there's a
moderate correlation between
what's happening in Tennessee.
We don't know why.
We have no idea why, but there's
some correlation
that's much greater than some
of the other states.
I see Virginia and Missouri.
And this could be any number of
things, like one hypothesis
could be that the plane
is late in New York.
And it flies to these other
airports, then it's
late the next day.
Because maybe the plane
has screwed up
the schedule or whatever.
FELIPE HOFFA: Or the weather
patterns have moved from one
place to another.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right,
weather patterns
and things like that.
I would never have guessed
Tennessee is the top one in
this example.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, that's
interesting.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's fantastic.
Is there another thing
we can do?
Can we do things by quarter?
Is there some way we can look
at different quarters?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, we can
improve the rate of maybe some
predictor is very good during
the summer, but during the
winter it makes no sense.
So let's look things at
things by quarter.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK,
now how do we do that?
FELIPE HOFFA: The correlation
goes through New York State.
What's the best predictor,
depending if it's now summer,
it's now spring.
So we need to add a new field.
Let's add quarters.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So we
have a function called
Quarter, and that operates
on timestamps.
Is that right?
So I need to do the same thing,
convert my date to a
time stamp and then use
the Quarter function.
So that's an easy one.
So I'll use quarter, quarter,
and then time
stamp, and then date.
And I'll call it q.
And I'll do the same thing
on both queries.
And then I have to change a few
things, because I'm adding
a parameter.
Do I add it here?
Should I just pick one quarter,
because they're being
joined on quarter?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
So I say a, q.
FELIPE HOFFA: And you need to
join on the quarter too now.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK, so I
join that, and aq equals b bq.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, they
will be equal.
But it's better if we--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Make sure
that they're joined.
OK, so I'm just going to report
one quarter there.
So this should run.
OK, so let's run this.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, we need to
reroute things because we have
a new field now, so one,
two and three.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Got it.
FELIPE HOFFA: And we author
by the first one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Excellent,
so this just makes
it really handy to
change things.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, now under sub
queries you also need to
add this [? set ?], because
they have a new [? set. ?]
You rule by one, two,
three for both.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Excellent.
I love the shorthand for this.
Great, so we're going
to run this again.
Let's do it, see
how this goes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Then
we're missing--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I believe
I don't have a space here.
FELIPE HOFFA: [INAUDIBLE]
be great.
I'm having to column
[? self ?] three.
Parenthesis.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Thank you.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank
you [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
it's running again.
FELIPE HOFFA: Running again,
this is a larger query.
Now we are segmenting
by departure.
We have the predictors.
We know that Tennessee is the
best predictor of New York.
[? But ?]
will that predictor work at
any time during the year.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Interesting, so I
see that the quarter--
that was the first quarter.
That's winter.
And so we can actually look at
some of these predictors, and
we can see which ones
are the quarters?
So I'm just going to
scroll through.
It's winter, winter, winter.
All of these kind of
correlations happening-- the
only one that's not the fourth
quarter of the year is the
first quarter--
also winter.
FELIPE HOFFA: First quarter,
it's spring.
[? That's ?] interesting.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: The
first quarter is
January, February, March.
It's pretty cold.
So I mean, this makes
a lot of sense.
And we don't see a lot of
anything in spring or summer
until maybe the 20th one,
and that's already
getting into the week.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly,
[INAUDIBLE]
the first time we have, if it
summer and you want to know
how late flights will be in
New York the next day.
Don't look at Tennessee.
Look at Ohio.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Exactly,
exactly, so you look at some
other states for that,
for when it comes
to the third quarter.
That is fantastic.
OK, this is great.
And I just want to take a
quick look at the least
correlated, which
is also in this.
And we have data for
some of these.
But of course, you get Hawaii
in the first quarter, Hawaii
in the second quarter.
So if you have a departure delay
in New York, there's no
way that it has any correlation
to departure
delays in Hawaii in any quarter,
it looks like.
Because I can scroll through
here and see.
So this is actually fantastic.
So we need to wrap
up pretty soon.
So we've gone through this.
This is really amazing, because
you can apply this to
any number of things.
And this is just a random
data set that I
like, which is flights.
But you can look
at retail data.
You could look at
your log data.
You could find anomalies or
stuff that you didn't expect
using correlation about two
variables that are not
connected or connected.
FELIPE HOFFA: On yesterday's
blog post, we talked about how
to find anomalies in data.
What is going weird on your
rooms using the data sensing
lab, we've started looking at
hey, things are behaving
pretty normal, or things
are behaving weird.
And with correlation, you can
get a quick alert of things
going not as expected.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Sure, so
correlation doesn't actually
tell you exactly what's going
on, but at least it points you
toward what could
be happening.
Like, a statistically
significant something is
happening with numerical
data, and what is it?
And you can use this technique
to find all those things.
FELIPE HOFFA: Today we were
looking at how to predict how
your flight time will be, and
maybe we could use it for more
things, like how about
segmenting your customers?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Exactly.
FELIPE HOFFA: You have millions
of customers.
Each one behaves in
different ways.
Can we segment that?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's fantastic.
You're going to find segments
that are correlations that you
probably didn't know about.
And it's up to you to explore.
And I love what you can
do with Big Queries.
You could explore these data
sets very quickly.
FELIPE HOFFA: Sadly, we won't
have time for that today, but
look forward for a future blog
post where we're looking at
that kind of correlations and
look forward for a lot of news
from the Big Query team.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: That
sounds fantastic.
And just before we wrap up,
where can people read your
blog posts, Felipe?
FELIPE HOFFA: So remember, we
have the Cloud [INAUDIBLE]
blog.
That's where we posted
yesterday.
Remember to follow
us on Google+.
We are on the--
what's the name of--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: The Google
Cloud Platform page.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly,
follow us there.
Find us.
We are on Google+ too--
Michael Manoochehri
and Felipe Hoffa.
If you have technical questions,
leave all of them
in Stack Overflow.
We, the team, everyone here,
really loves Stack Overflow,
and that's what we like
answering everything.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Looks great.
And what I want to know is if
people are using Core, please
please let us know.
Post to our Google+ page and let
us know what you're doing.
And we would love to see what
you're doing with this.
Because I think it's very
powerful, and it's something
that you don't see in the
other technology.
FELIPE HOFFA: Running
correlations, multivariate
analysis, [INAUDIBLE]
decisions, we are
happy to see.
Yesterday, we [? will ?]
go to this.
This is going in a really
massive space.
So hopefully, we'll get
to play with this.
Hopefully, you will get to
share your space with us.
And I expect to see you soon.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Thank
you very much.
I'm Michael Manoochehri.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank
you, Michael.
I'm Felipe Hoffa.